lo que quiero calcular en este vídeo es
53 + 17 y la forma en la que quiero
calcular esta suma es partiendo al 53 en
dos pedazos y reagrupando los números y
vas a ver a qué me refiero en unos
cuantos segundos y bueno 53 más 17 es
igual y ahora sí vamos a partir el 53
básicamente lo vamos a partir en sus
decenas y sus unidades entonces 53 se
puede reescribir como 50 más 350 más 353
no y bueno podemos poner unos paréntesis
alrededor de estas cosas curvas son los
paréntesis este abre el paréntesis y
éste cierra el paréntesis y lo que
significa este paréntesis es que hay que
hacer la operación que está aquí adentro
antes que lo que esté afuera del
paréntesis entonces 53 es 50 más 3 y nos
falta poner más 17 más
17 y bueno en este punto podemos hacer
primero la suma de adentro del
paréntesis y después sumarle 17 pero
entonces simplemente nos regresamos a
esto que tenemos aquí ahora nosotros
queremos saber cuánto vale 53 más 17
entonces pues vamos a cambiar el orden
en el que hacemos estas sumas ok esto
que tenemos aquí es igual a 50 50 más
tres más tres más diecisiete pero ahora
vamos a sumar el 3 y el 17 primero
ok y esa es una de las propiedades de la
suma que siempre que esté sumando puedes
cambiar el orden en el que haces estas
sumas por aquí estamos sumando primero
50 más 3 y por acá estamos sumando
primero tres más 17
y esto cuánto es igual pues tenemos por
aquí el 50
en cuenta más y ahora cuánto es 317 pues
tres más 7 es 10 entonces 317 es 20
entonces tenemos 50 más 20
cuanto vale esto pues esto son cinco
decenas más dos decenas así es que esta
suma son siete decenas siete decenas o
sea setenta ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio uno de esos ejercicios que
podría llegar a encontrarte en la página
de khan academy y vamos a colocarlo por
acá y dice completa para resolver 41 más
9 así es que otra vez este 41 lo podemos
partir en dos pedazos lo podemos partir
en 40 más que cosa pues tendría que ser
40 más 1 y luego pues tenemos que
sumarle 9 aunque esté 9 es el mismo 9 de
aquí que le tenemos que sumar a 41 y
entonces pues vamos al siguiente renglón
esto que tenemos aquí es exactamente
igual a 40 más
+ 9 pues aquí tiene que ir un 1 cierto y
en este reglón lo que estamos haciendo
es primero sumar el 19 pero pues qué
pasa si primero sumamos 1 más 9 pues 19
es 10
y observa como esta caja este espacio
está sustituyendo a todo este paréntesis
en el paréntesis teníamos 19 y eso es 10
y ahora cuánto es 40 más 10 pues son 4
decenas más una decena y esa suma son
cinco decenas o sea 50 y listo ya
terminamos